[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in drew bledsoe the former
nfl quarterback uh former number one
overall pick and uh was the star of
episode one of man in the arena
the uh docu-series about tom brady did
you know you were gonna be the star of
episode one drew
well i haven't seen it uh so uh you know
i uh no i i didn't know until right now
that i was actually the star of that
show i thought it was about uh tom brady
yeah but it's about you
and the early days when you got the
injury and tom takes over and tom
becomes the super bowl uh winner
uh
so you have you i know you lived it but
you have no interest in watching this
well i mean i'm not gonna not watch it
but uh you know i'm up here i'm making
wine and walla walla right now so i
don't know
you know i'm sure i'm sure it'll come on
at some point and i'll check it out but
no man it's a you know that uh i'm i'm
still great friends with tommy and so
proud of what he's done um but i'm
pretty well versed in the story
i actually i've i've actually seen the
movie i was in the middle of it
but
no i'm uh i'm proud of tommy and uh you
know i love everything about the kids so
i'll probably uh i'm sure i'll watch it
at some point but i was wondering that
you you made yourself vulnerable you
made yourself available for this but you
made yourself vulnerable because you
talked about
you guys win the super bowl
and you go home you're on the the
mountains you're skiing and all of a
sudden it hits you
and you break down why did it hit you
then yeah you know well i mean you know
when you're when you're in the middle of
something like that you know you don't
you know you're being a leader and
you're uh
um you know trying to do the right thing
for your team and you just have to be
strong you know you have to be strong
and so i was i was that through the
through all of that and then
once you get away from that you no
longer have the responsibility of of uh
you know
being a leader for the team and and uh
wearing all of that and that all comes
off and now you don't have to be that
responsible party anymore now you can
kind of let it let it sink in a little
bit so yeah it was i mean it wasn't uh
you know it was a that was a that was a
long and difficult year but then also
had a happy ending and like it just was
like this most bittersweet thing ever
where your team
goes on and wins the championship but uh
but you're not on the field um you know
it was uh
it was it was
very happy for my squad and very sad for
myself
but you helped win the game against the
steelers in the afc title game what part
of you thinks you're going to start in
the super bowl because i only i think it
was a week in between or they didn't
have the weekend between did they did
you have the game sunday and then super
bowl was next the following sunday yeah
the following week it was pretty quick
and i think uh i think like wednesday or
thursday or that week uh belichick let
me let me know that uh that he was gonna
start tom in the super bowl which you
know that part was you know it's like
you know if you're starving and somebody
gives you a cracker
you know you haven't played all year and
uh now you're now you're there and you
get to the top of the mountain in the
biggest game that there is and finally
got to play a little bit and get back on
the field and uh next thing you know the
uh
you know the other guy's going back out
there
do you have any recollection of getting
hit by mo lewis that day
you know not really i i
um i remember
you know i remember kind of laying there
on the sidelines and and getting up and
then i just remember
you know i remember going back and going
back in the game and and uh
you know i mean i certainly wasn't all
there i had a pretty serious concussion
i think in addition to the internal
stuff but i remember turning around and
asking mark edwards hey mark how do i
you know i know i had to go left
hey mark how do i go left he goes say
odd like oh yeah ah and then we ran play
left and then he went
he went uh he and uh damon heward were
the ones that ratted me out that i
wasn't uh wasn't all there because i
went to damon to go over our two-minute
plays and our two-minute plays have been
the same for
years you know it would uh
you know be you know like you coming
into your show and asking which chair do
i sit in uh it's it's kind of that kind
of uh that kind of a simplistic thing
and so that's when they went and said
hey he's not uh
he's not all there and that's when the
uh that's when they put tommy in and
then
after the game i tried to go home
thankfully the doctors didn't let me do
that
but you had i mean if they let you go
home
yeah after let me go home out of diet i
was bleeding out at about a liter an
hour internally and by the time they got
me the hospital i was i was out and they
took a lot of blood out of my body
thankfully they uh they were able to
recycle my blood and put it back in so
they didn't have to open my chest up um
but it was uh it was touch and go there
for a while you're pretty nonchalant
about this
well you know i lived
[Laughter]
no i didn't i didn't know how serious
what serious it was until two or three
days after so i wasn't really aware that
there was that it was really bad until a
few days later ever talked to moe lewis
you know i never have he's never sent me
flowers
[Laughter]
how about this how about this
a mo lewis wine called internal bleeding
oh god yeah well i don't know i just did
is it too soon
internal red how about internal red yeah
there you go yeah
what would you say if if you saw moe
lewis that one of these nfl functions
i'll give him a hug i don't i don't i
don't have any animosity toward him
whatsoever you know and you uh you know
you opened this segment talking about
the roughing the passer stuff well back
that that hit was not penalized and it
wasn't illegal you know that was just
the way that the game was played i was
you know i was heading toward out of
bounds but i wasn't out of bounds he hit
me it was it was a hard hit but it was
uh in that day and age was a clean hit
today would have been a targeting call
and he would have been fine fifty
thousand dollars and uh and all that but
uh you know they've changed the game
with with the intent of trying to you
know trying to keep quarterbacks in the
field now they've obviously gone way
overboard i mean you know you run by a
quarterback and look at him the wrong
way and you hurt his feelings that's 15
yards
but
but do quarterbacks want this drew
because brady said this is the reason
why he's able to play at 44.
but
do you want it as a quarterback
you know i i i think as a fan and you
know and as a quarterback i understand
the
desire and the need to protect these
star players because you know you want
them on the field uh but they've just
they've gone too far with it you know i
mean you know the uh and i think that
the the you know the hard part is i
think for defenders you know they have
to come in and they have to be thinking
about you know not you know they're
going as hard as they can against the
strongest dudes on the planet trying to
get there and all of a sudden they get
there and now when they get there now
they have to stop and
pull off and and it's uh so yes they've
gone too far with it i understand the
the intent of what they're doing but
they've gone too far with it in my
opinion
and
i've just made it almost impossible to
uh to play defense in a lot of in a lot
of ways
he's drew bledsoe former nfl quarterback
former number one overall pick uh and i
know you didn't come on to talk about
your wine but let people know about your
uh wine that you've been
oh yeah thanks man no we we're out here
making macon wine in my hometown walla
walla
got a kick-ass team that is uh you know
doing everything we own our own
vineyards and make the wine and deliver
it and we're you know i think they're
making some of the very best wine in the
world for us it's been a lot of fun it's
called double back if you want to find
it doubleback.com okay if i want to
sound like i know
about wine
give me some terminology here yeah um so
you want some really wine geeky stuff if
you have a wine and you like it and then
it's like you know you can just say you
know this is a complete wine this is uh
this has got great balance nice
structure nice tannin good fruit you
know and you can just say it's a
complete wine and the wine geeks will
leave you alone because then you sound
like you really know what you're talking
about
complex
complex completely yeah yeah
are you better at wine or quarterbacking
oh man you know it's they're very
similar in a lot of ways and that you
know i was playing quarterback i had a
bunch of badass dudes that did the
really hard work in front of me and fast
guys
and then i got to take all the credit
right you know and uh and it's the same
in this i you know i direct a team that
uh that just kicks ass and makes me look
good
is mac jones good or just in a good
situation
both
both you know he's uh he's doing exactly
what he's supposed to do he's accurate
uh working within the framework of a
good offense um
but uh you know that's the deal i mean
in the in the in the nfl
uh
you know you need all of it in order to
win uh and he's playing very well uh but
he's also in a good system and in a
on a team that looks like they're rising
at the right time but knowing belichick
what do you think he says to mack jones
daily basis or on game day
she's i don't know not very much you
know i mean he he trusts his he trusts
his uh his staff to
to work with him um you know he's far
from verbose when it comes to coaching
up the quarterbacks but um but you know
mack is a guy that sounds like a need
they they do their research they know
what they're drafting and they you know
there's a guy that's working really hard
smart guy doing all of the doing all the
little things he has to do during the
week and then
game day you know you start as a
quarterback you always have to start
with don't make a mistake first don't
hurt your team
and he's doing that which is which is uh
the most important part of the job uh
but then beyond that he's throwing the
ball accurately getting out of his hands
he's really doing a nice job but so
belichick really is not involved in
quarterbacks
you know at least he wasn't for the
couple years that i was there he you
know i mean you know we meet with him
and he knows what's going on and and i
know tommy you know met with him quite a
bit over the years just like early in
early in weeks um you know there'll be
little things here and there but but uh
you know he really lets uh you know josh
mcdaniels
handled that side of the world for him
and and uh so yeah i don't think he's
probably not telling him the whole time
yeah i was wondering about that because
if you're brady and then you want out of
there like can you have fun in there
like what what constitutes having fun
that maybe tom was missing in new
england
i don't know i mean he stayed for 20
years i mean come on listen you know i
mean it had can't have been that
miserable uh but he was winning and
winning
and they were winning and winning kind
of cures everything winning is always
fun uh
but uh i remember tommy did tell me a
story a few years ago i think that was
like they've been together 17 years
something like that and it's like he's
built is he kind of lightened up over
the years
and he goes man you know there are times
when like he'll walk by me in the
hallway and not say hi
you know after 17 years the most
successful run of a quarterback
and coach ever and you know like yeah
yeah he's still kind of the same guy
he's just very focused very business but
he uh no you can have fun i mean come on
it's football they had a lot of fun um
and bill actually you know he can
lighten up and have fun yeah everybody
says that
jesus did i saw him at a wine deal one
time um
right after we had started he came over
and brought bears his assistant they
came over and they were there you know
sipping on some wine he was laughing he
was joining i was like man who who is
this imposter
and what have they done with belichick
because that's not the guy i played for
but he uh you know he gets uh you get
him outside of a football setting and he
actually uh he actually can lighten up
and have some fun by the way
drew has a uh a cab that just got 95
points
i think your cab got 95 right
yeah i don't know this one's wine
credits
wine critics and sports writers they're
all the same come on
no
i always
they've been they've been really they've
been really good to us
the critics have been but i always feel
like we deserve more but
um but uh no they their critics have
been good to us um and uh the wine sells
fast but i just always feel like our
team has done such a killer job that
they need more than 95 points but you
don't want 95 as a quarterback rating do
you um
well you know there were some times when
i would have taken it
but you know particularly in buffalo
when it's pissing down rain and blowing
sideways
if i could complete two or three passes
i felt like i was doing pretty good what
made you want to go to buffalo
well it wasn't my choice they traded me
to buffalo yeah but could you have said
i don't want to go to buffalo
i could i could have played you know
hardball said i was gonna retire or
whatever um and done that but you know i
think the reaction though it's like
everybody that goes to buffalo i think
has a similar reaction because nobody
chooses that right you're like oh i
don't want to be exiled to western new
york and play in the rain and all that
but then once you're there as a player
it's it's awesome i mean i loved playing
there i think most guys that end up
going there end up really loving playing
there the fans are fantastic
um the weather is atrocious um but it's
it's really a cool place to play well
it's like playing pro ball in a college
town you know and uh
you know so it's kind of funny because i
don't know how many people ever choose
to choose buffalo as a free agent but
but once you get there it's pretty
awesome
great to talk to you
are you featured in any more of these
episodes are you one and done with uh
tom brady
i truly have no idea dan i really don't
i my my my guess is probably just the
one because then they move on and
uh but uh um but i don't know i'll have
to go check it out was brady a better
beer chugger than you
he actually was pretty fast i i you know
i never i was never very fast drinking
beer it was you know it was more of a
slow volume game but uh
he could back in the day he could he
could uh he could he could shotgun a
beer pretty fast ross tucker talks about
brady as an old-timer
yeah no he was he was
he was pretty good at that now i mean
you know now he doesn't even
drink at all i think he has a little bit
of red wine in the off season he
actually did
you know we couldn't ship wine to
massachusetts for a long time and so i
sent his first shipment of wine i sent
to his dad in california and his dad
drank it all
uh but i think he i think he will have a
glass of wine every now and then um you
know maybe in the off season but uh i
don't know if i wonder when the last
time was that he actually had a beer i
really have no idea well might have been
on the boat
yeah it sounds like he had a lot of
something mommy was on the boat but i
don't know if that was beer yeah sounds
like it was tequila uh hey great to talk
to you again as always and uh good luck
with the cab and uh thanks for joining
us
you got it buddy i'll come see you next
time i'm in uh connecticut yeah
stop by stop by for a meet friday
okay we'll do it and bring wine
will do okay
that's drew bledsoe the former nfl
quarterback